大きめ
お兄様
私
この私
前社長の弟
肇社長の弟
私所
私を
ずっとはくれませんでしょうか
雇ってはくれませんでしょうかえっ
味
マジです
定常だここに2つとまじめに話しましょう
どうぞどうぞなーんてしまう失礼します
俺楽しいお兄ちゃん肇社長ですそして
古城とうとうの健です
やぁ久しぶりです健さんおひさしぶりっ
一票はそんなに二ヶ月ぶりぐらいじゃない
ともうズバリ
入っちゃいますよねちゃ
はい
脇肇社長の
弟は
[音楽]
こちらにおります
実の兄
肇社長の
会社で
働かせていて徹底て飛びましたね働かせて
いただきたいと
重い本日させていただきましょう
ようこそ
アブいいんですか働いてしまってちょっと
考えたしてください上がりましたあの傾い
ななんかあなたが就職する前に私は
アドバイスしたと思うんですよ昔一応
最後に聞きたいことがあるんだからお前
[音楽]
ユーチューバーにならねーか
たセアは不肇社長の弟となってデビュー
すればこういう道もあるんじゃないかと
そうですねあなたございましたよねー
こと終わらせていただきましたねその時は
うん1本
まあユーチューバーなわけじゃないんです
けどもそこからちゃんと同じが説明させて
いただきますまあほんと今言った通り実は
ですね
をはじめした町野根母として肇社長
とうとうが一緒に
お仕事することになりました
よろしくお願いますあこちらこそよろしく
お願いしますっていうことはもう仕事は
辞めたということですか
はい
やめて1人なんてったの白いドアの人に
仕事場の人にはもちろん
いきなり
その兄が
ユーチューバーしててやっを言ったら肇
社長っていや最初に入ってないお
自営業をしている家族が入ってその仕事の
手伝いとして今誘われている状態でまだ
考えている状態なんですかねちょっと話を
今聴いている状態なんですがそこだけ頭の
方に入れて浮いてもらっていいですかなん
か口を固くいっても者日会社の阿蘇へね
ちゃんと話どうして止められたということ
でそういうその後もまあやっぱり兄貴と
の家族とかと話をしておこう
チャンスをもらえるんだろう
というこそ今じゃあ20
はい歳なんですけど10代後半とだからね
うんウディ水から考える人がいるようで
そうですね
話だと思うけど今しかできないチャンスを
もらえるならチャレンジしてみるのが
すごいね動画のタイトル的にはなんか弟か
雇わせてくださいった感じだっていうん
ですけどもどっちかというと僕からまず話
を持ち出した感じでして
なんかねえ
かあさんだけに任せられないというか
間に来た気持ちだぞ実はあの肇社長のお
金まわり本当に蛍光何か言ってるんです
けども全部
うちのお母様が管理しておりまして年か
正直かなり負担というかなんか親孝行なの
かなみたいな4
というか母さんが死んだろう今行ってる僕
のは中津縁起でもない話なんですけどかあ
さんが多くっと本当に今いなくなってる
から馬にタイプやばいいじゃないですか
正直お金まわりとか
どれだけ稼げてるかもわからないですよね
あっはぁもう本当に全部前のに丸だけで
パツン的にはは勝目あったは動画に集中し
てほしいからお金かかる気にせず
月などがやってくると
いうことでお金関係お待たせてたんです
けどもっと今入った鳥もつ突然ね今泉新で
かわかんてから人間っていうかそもそも俺
が死んだら元もないんですけど河童誰所望
さの新聞可能性があるという中でももし仮
に家のね俺たちのお母様がうちの会社の肇
社長の金回りを管理して人がいなくなっ
たら本当に多分
終わりなんですよはじめたつん
まじで終わっちゃうと思ってるんでその
ポジションを誰かに任せようかなと思った
ときに
[音楽]
なんか俺は木目が出てきたっていう
いやほんと実際声かけてもらって
単純に合った仕事を辞めるのかそういう話
で部分を完全にやり日から言ってもらえて
嬉しいだって思ったのも正直あってそれも
組でが余計だった
かタイマー弟のすごいところは3年間
ちゃんと解説と目でしっかり働き切った
ところ1年目で見る人が多い座
いた所
めっちゃいただいていたその中でさんと3
年間働き切ったのは私評価しております
超食宝でや早く仕上げていることなんです
けどまあそういう社会経験含め
よろしく働いていたので表に出ると休館
裏の部分
母ちゃんがは凸に行ったわけじゃないです
けどもねかどっちかというとバックヤード
を裏方として外したソンの弟一緒に良い
そことやっていければいいなと思って今回
お知らせさせて頂いたおります
[音楽]
食べて扱っていい
まあ
たまにならああいう是政はいいんだろう
顔出し所
ちょっと考えさせてもらうわかりました
そのうち出るかもしれないということで
やー
youtube の世界はどう思ってるん
ですかyoutube の世界は正直今も
兄貴を
はいはラク出すいうとじゃないことですよ
ね俺もねー
それを持った楽しいから続けてるだけで
あって楽しそうだなっていうのもあって
その色だよね
の中で楽しそういう
おじゃるし楽しめるんじゃないかという
文字でトルコ
がとうございますただやっぱり基本的に裏
形になると思うんでパリの楽しいこと
ばかりじゃないと思いますご座俺は正しい
ことばかりじゃないけど
と肇社長の裏の部分というか
backyard しっかり任せるように
なっても
いろいろでできることだからと思ってした
言葉に宜しくお願いします翌朝ん
こんなことになるとは思わんかったわ普通
よあの大学卒業したてのを問われた動画で
これで終わりだからねそうよね別々の域に
入ったらあっ
3保険物の管理だったりとかいることが俺
一人だとできないことだけダメでして
いただけるとファイル c でした
バランシングライブありがとうございませ
ん弟から離れたというふうに俺が何となく
話だしてみたらあじゃあ是非お知演奏がに
したくないと言うか何か gt の変化だ
と思ったわけでしょそう
パンストこれは厳しいよ
野手としている編と厳しいの両方
家族だからと言ってそんなんかまた
よろしくお願いしたいと俺は思ってないん
だよはい
お願いします会社のメインだからたまに
使っていいねさん
でまあ
たまによありがとうございました車なんか
立場が逆にいうわけでのバックヤードと
いうか裏方にスタッフとしの事が入ると
いう動画でしたよろしくお願います宜しく
お願いします
[音楽]
ええええええ
dejiん
うぉ
た